[Musica]
sono sovrappeso sono alto un metro e 73
e peso 82 kg come l'ha scoperto esami
sulla bilancia o una bilancia che mi
mette in questa simpatica a tutti i dati
e mi ricorda quanto sto peggiorando
nella mia dieta per questa cosa un po di
scuse diciamo c'è stato lock down è nata
mia figlia
sono stato in vacanza in puglia dove si
mangia parecchio bene se invece mi peso
per quello che è l'impatto ambientale
che io come individuo metto nel mondo
sono molto sovrappeso come si fa ci sono
diversi modi
io ho usato un calcolatore del vv.f ma
ognuno di voi potrebbe scoprirlo domani
e sono molto sovrappeso circa del 39 per
cento
cosa vuol dire vuol dire che oggi
producono circa il 40 per cento in più
dell'anidride carbonica rispetto a
quella che dovrà immettere nell'ambiente
per salvaguardare il nostro pianeta ora
capite che questa cosa ha un po meno
scuse mentre prima per la dieta avevo un
po di scuse qui direi che in questo caso
l'unica cosa che ho fatte forse mi sono
guardato poco in casa
il che è un paradosso perché lavoro per
un'azienda che fa della sua missione
il fatto di combattere le emissioni di
co2 nell'atmosfera misurare una dieta
calorica oggi è abbastanza facile
esistono delle app come questa che vi
sto mostrando in cui inserisco quando
quello che ha mangiato sottraggo lo
sport e l'attività fisica che ho fatto
e alla fine mi dà un'indicazione di dove
sto andando
quando parliamo invece di co2 è un po
più incasinata la situazione non è così
facile sapere dove deve intervenire
quali sono i cibi su cui deve
intervenire della mia dieta ambientale e
quando ho scoperto questo secondo
sovrappeso quello ambientale
ho scoperto anche una cosa che non mi
era evidente che un terzo di questo
sovrappeso viene da casa mia ma allora
tipicamente ci concentriamo tutti su il
come come viaggiamo cosa mangiamo cosa
compriamo quando pensiamo al nostro
impatto ambientale ma realtà tutto
questo è vero
ma per due terzi della nostra del nostro
impatto ambientale perché un terzo viene
da casa mia è come se io dicessi che li
famosi 82 kg che mi porto appresso 27
siedono in casa mia e posso anche
ragionevolmente ipotizzare che
ultimamente questi chili magari sono
aumentati un po di più visto che
facciamo un uso un po più intenso delle
case grazie a quello che sta succedendo
ora la casa la casa è il luogo dove noi
consumiamo tanta energia la casa mangia
tanta energia per rimanere in tema dieta
è una cosa interessante è che le case in
italia sono molto vecchie il 70 per
cento delle case in media ha più di 35
anni ora capite che 35 anni fa gli
standard con cui si progettava e
costruire una casa erano molto diversi
rispetto ad oggi
in più poi cosa abbiamo fatto in questi
35 anni queste case li abbiamo riempite
di elettrodomestici elettrodomestici che
fanno il loro lavoro che funzionano ma a
volte no
e noi ci accorgiamo solo quando si
rompono e per mantenere il consumo delle
nostre case dentro un range è
accettabile e quindi l'impatto
ambientale accettabile
non dobbiamo solo accorgersi quando
funzionano bene e quando si rompono
ma come stanno funzionando nel tempo ora
abbiamo due problemi o il problema della
mia dieta il problema della dieta di
casa mia o come faccio a controllare la
dieta di casa mia senza una bilancia
senza un modo di sapere quali sono i
cibi che metto dentro casa mia sembra
non avere una visione un po disperata
del mondo ma c'è un messaggio di
speranza
il messaggio di speranza è che se
possiamo misurare possiamo migliorare e
oggi ci sono degli strumenti che ci
aiutano a fare questo e sorpresa
sorpresa non sono le bollette le
bollette vi danno un'informazione che
non mi dà la possibilità diciamo di
intervenire a casa vostra perché perché
arrivano con due mesi di ritardo e
perché tipicamente l'informazione
contenuta è un numero un numero che non
ci permette di agire ma
arriva la tecnologia arriva la
tecnologia e passiamo da un mondo in cui
per misurare casa vostra
dovete avere un termostato intelligente
elettrodomestici intelligenti rese
intelligenti per elettrodomestici
stupidi e poi qualcuno di intelligente
che mi metta insieme tutti questi dati
per effettivamente capire dove devo
andare
arriva la tecnologia e parliamo di una
riduzione del numero di sensori che ci
servono a 2
bastano due sensori che vanno nel punto
da cui passa l'energia di casa vostra
che sono il quadro elettrico e la
caldaia questi sensori ci permettono di
capire cose che sono molto simili a
quello che fa la perché abbia mostrato
prima e che ci fa capire come la nostra
casa
mangia energia per esempio scopriamo
quanto consumiamo quando non siamo in
casa quando lasciamo le spie accese
quanto consuma casa nostra quando noi
non ci siamo
scopriamo di cosa è fatto il consumo di
casa nostra quindi quel numero che
vediamo in bolletta si è fatto da tempo
che spendo a lavare tempo che spendo
raffrescare casa mia eccetera eccetera e
poi scopriamo come si comportano gli
elettrodomestici quindi se il frigo per
esempio consuma come un tempo
o sta peggiorando e tutte queste cose
diciamo sono informazioni che ci
arrivano in tempo reale e non a mesi di
distanza come oggi succede per esempio
quelle bollette e poi scopriamo anche
cosa è un po meno intuitive per esempio
quante volte la caldaia parte e non
riesce a riscaldare l'acqua con cui noi
vorremmo lavarci le mani
sì perché questa è una cosa interessante
che si vede leggendo questi dati
praticamente tipicamente noi quello che
facciamo per lavarci le mani
apriamo l'acqua al massimo della
temperatura perché vogliamo l'acqua
calda
la caldaia parte amici le per cercare di
riscaldare l'acqua il più velocemente
possibile e inquina consumiamo un sacco
e tipicamente quello che si vede dai
dati è che però alla fine l'acqua
l'acqua non è così calda quella con cui
ci laviamo le mani e quindi abbiamo
inquinato abbiamo speso ed abbiamo pure
rovinato la caldaia perché le abbiamo
fatto fare uno sforzo molto importante
ora vedendo queste cose capite che ci
avviciniamo un mondo in cui finalmente
avremo una bilancia per pesare non solo
il peso di casa nostra ma anche come è
fatta la dieta e i cibi che la che
questa casa mangia in termini di energia
la bella notizia oltre al fatto che sta
arrivando alla tecnologia e che quando
mettiamo a dieta casa nostra è una
soluzione come direbbero i figli che
parlano inglese win win win
perché una casa ecologica fa bene alla
vostra salute
fa bene al vostro comfort perché più
confortevole fa bene al vostro
portafogli e in ultima analisi fa bene
anche all'ambiente
quindi parliamo di una soluzione win win
win ma come ogni dieta che si rispetti
la bilancia l'abbiamo l'abbiamo trovata
nel parlato prima cosa serve serve
qualcuno che non vi faccia fare una
dieta fai da te ma che sia il vostro
dietologo il vostro consulente e che vi
dica cosa dovete fare e dove dovete
intervenire in questo e ci credo
talmente tanto che ho costruito
un'azienda attorno a questo concetto
credo che i fornitori di energia debbano
giocare la propria parte ma per arrivare
a fare quel ruolo del consulente mancano
un paio di cose la prima devono fare in
modo che voi vi fidiate di loro perché
non prendereste mai una dieta da
qualcuno di cui non vi fidate devono poi
parlare come voi devono cominciare a
farci capire perché perché non
prendereste mai una dieta da qualcuno
che non riesce a spiegarmi bene cosa
dovete fare è la verità è che
l'argomento energia è o meglio è rimasto
ancora un po complicato quindi c'è un po
di lavoro da fare ma per chiudere questa
dieta e per chiudere questo discorso ci
sono altre due cose che voglio dirvi la
prima come ogni dieta che si rispetti è
buono iniziare da un piccolo passo e il
piccolo passo ve lo do io oggi ed è
quello di controllare così come fate per
i vostri cibi la provenienza
dell'energia di casa vostra
re tendete che i vostri fornitori di
energia siano trasparenti con voi e vi
mostrino i dati della provenienza e
dell'impatto ambientale di ciò che la
vostra casa consuma come ultima cosa per
una dieta di successo serve un motivo
la motivazione alla base lo dicono tutti
tutti gli esperti dicono che per
riuscire in una dieta serve una
motivazione molto forte
io la mia motivazione cielo ed è mia
figlia voi
sono sicuro che non lo farete perchè ve
l'ha detto un ragazzo che vendeva luce e
gas leggermente sovrappeso
durante inter tocca padova grazie
[Musica]